Paulie noticed that March 24 2005 the
office debuted and he so he sent me a
text last night he said hey see if Brian
Baumgartner who played Kevin from the
office can join us and I sent a text and
Brian got back to me right away and
thanks for joining us Brian oh I'm
definitely in my sweat pants man what do
you what are you they're so comfy what
are you watching at home what am i
watching at home you know I just watched
that dumb [ __ ] someone said oh this is
the thing to watch while you're
quarantine
Tyco Tigers yeah yes I'm I started god I
couldn't get through it i I just
couldn't do it I said I'm not blessing
I'm not this desperate for entertainment
and I just I watched about 30 minutes
and I went nope
I cannot do it very very good call by
you Dan very good call by you but you
know what people are watching I think is
the office of course you know how many
times do you because it's played all the
time on Comedy Central
do you when's the last time you said you
know watch an episode you know I I
watched them all and I often do not
watch myself I watched them all when
they aired I don't know if you know that
the first couple of years we all watched
them together we would go to each
other's houses and watch the episodes
because we were so excited about the
show and then when it really took off we
got to but we were off in filming when
the show was actually airing on
television but I watched every episode
as it went through and then I would kind
of catch a scene or an episode here
there about six months ago six nine
months ago I went back from Episode one
I watched the whole thing all the way
through and I just I I was just so
delighted I loved it it really holds up
what's your favorite episode Wow I mean
I think for for me there's a lot of
other things tied into it I think for
pure comedy
it is very difficult to argue against
the injury or Michael burns his foot on
a George Foreman grill pure comedy I
think that one that one is hard to be
I'm very fun but I think part of it is
also like you know there are other
outside factors that are in there was a
two-part episode called stress relief
which you know if you just watched it on
Netflix you didn't know this but that
episode aired after the Superbowl and
that was a that was a real special when
that one is where Dwight does the fake
fire drill he blights the fire and
everybody goes crazy and Stanley has a
heart attack and we do CPR on people
which I don't know if you heard that
that saved someone's life did you ever
hear that tutorial don't want someone in
Arizona driving along the highway I'm
kind of making up some of the details
but basically pulls over someone's
having a heart attack on the side of the
road and Michael's singing a song
Michael sing a song no no I'm talking
about in real life in real life this guy
in Arizona comes across someone having a
heart attack on the side of the road and
he doesn't know CPR but he watched the
office and so he's busy stayin alive
stayin alive and the guy stayed alive
the ambulance came and and the office
hit at least one person's life yes we're
trying to talking to Brian Baumgartner
who played Kevin from the office how did
you get your voice on the office you
know it it it kind of it kind of
developed I would say you know when it
when it started out you know my
character of Kevin was was you know sort
of modeled after the character of Keith
on the British version of the show and
so the character sort of started there
but the the writers and Greg Daniels our
genius showrunner wanted you know wanted
the the cast to be larger wanted more
voices in there and so as the writers
started writing for me he and and began
to find his certain sensibility I don't
know about the actual voice that you you
you you dumb yourself down but it's not
your idea
well yeah I'm a trained actor Dan my bad
yeah Michael people do get surprised
when they hear my voice for the first I
was when I ran into I think at the
Dallas Super Bowl was like hey how are
you Brian and then you when you spoke
and I went oh wait a minute
[Laughter]
right I
how often does that happen when they see
a hate oh hey nice to meet you I do the
Kevin voice Oh a lot a lot or and the
other thing is like it's you know that
the Goodfellas the Joe Pesci thing like
what am I your clouds come up and be
like oh just say this say this for me
say say kool-aid man no I'm not gonna
say kool-aid man right now was a
kool-aid man face was Steve Carell the
first choice you know Steve Carell
became the first choice it was it
basically got down to as I understand it
Steve Carell and very very very
brilliant actor who's done incredibly
well for himself Bob Odenkirk bitter
cold no matter
better call Saul and raking back yes yes
he would have been he would have been a
slightly probably a slightly smarter
version right you know like like Bob
sort of has that like I you know I get
things whereas whereas Michael Scott
with the crow a little more naivete
right like a little yeah not quite as
with it but they're just so many of
those when you put your feet in the ice
machine the wedding episode we've had
you on to talk about the chilly episode
the basketball show did those guys know
you could play basketball
no the basketball that that that was the
I mean it was the first season but
that's probably my most
proudest accomplishment I sent messages
at the time to like my old high school
buddies who you know like it ended up
becoming athletes or whatever like hey
have you made 13 in a row from free
throw distance on national television no
no I'm not sure many have really I mean
anyone
I think I'm up there with Jordan that's
pretty good
was there a script where you went uh-oh
this could be disaster the chili really
I would have thought diversity day
because that was like the sole that was
second episode wasn't it
you know I will truthfully the diversity
day when we were filming diversity day
and you know we were all still kidding
so it was the first episode we had shot
one episode we shot the pilot and then
we went away for you know essentially
six seven eight months we got picked up
we came back in diversity day with the
next script and as we were filming I
swear to you as we were filming I said
you know I don't know if people are
going to give the show a chance but if
they do man what we're doing is
something pretty freakin special because
the way that that we were talking about
you know a serious obviously topic and
America you know race in America it just
wasn't done on television really you
could say going back to like all in the
family with Archie Bunker like like
addressing race in a in a comedic but
serious way III was just so tremendously
proud of that episode and you know some
people say you know we did 200 and
whatever episode you know 200 and
whatever half hours of television and
our second episode it was early and
characters were still finding themselves
but it could have been our best one yeah
and don't take this the wrong way I hope
there is no reunion like I I like when
things I don't like sequels to movies I
I this was so iconic this was
spectacular and I don't need to do so
reboot here yeah I yeah who knows I mean
I truly like if there was any
information I well I probably wouldn't
tell you right now but I texted tell me
but you in time I might
to you but I I'll tell you it I think
why it keeps coming up is by basically
any metric that you can calculate it is
the most watched show in television
right now and we haven't filmed a single
scene in six years
flow I don't know if you saw this
statistic on March 15th now you know
we're going through it a tough time time
in this country but on Saturday March
15th 249 million minutes were watched of
the office I mean it's it's it's you
can't even III think the last year that
they released was 2018 fifty two billion
minutes watch I mean by any metric you
can all calculate its it is it is it is
more popular than that I mean I have 12
year old 13 year olds you know coming up
to me all that and I'm like you were
born you were born when I was you know
had Italian on my forehead and acted
like an idiot in diversity day like you
weren't literally not born it's crazy
that's crazy and what's like friends you
know friends has a new life in a new
generation following that show as well
yes for sure it's you know and it's you
know I think that the the crazy thing
for me is I think we all like I remember
when we went it with when it was
starting and we were saying like oh you
know there's I don't know however many
million people who work in an office in
America right so this has got to appeal
to some people like and and and now it's
so not that it's so much the younger
people that I think at the time we
started making it was not even a
considerate like we weren't thinking
about that because by the way like
spoiler alert a lot of the people in the
cast
maybe all of them didn't look like TV
stars right
about friend-friend that's true
I didn't think about that that is true
yeah and we were and it was like you
know someone told me you know at that
time if you if you were not very young
and very attractive it was difficult to
get on on a comedy on television and you
know it's it's what it what has happened
to it is is crazy and it's really fun
and I think ultimately I it it holds up
and I'm proud of it so that makes it
that makes it okay well thanks for
joining us and congrats on all the
success with that the office debuted
March 24th 2005 Brian Baumgartner who
played Kevin from the office good to
talk to you again Brian Dan always my
pleasure stay safe my friend all righty